what is the chi-square test the  chi-square test is a hypothesis test  that is used when you want to determine  if there is a relationship between two  categorical variables what are  categorical variables again categorical  variables are for example gender with  the categories male and female or the  preferred newspaper with the categories  USA Today The Wall Street Journal the  New York Times and so on if we now have  two categorical variables and we want to  test whether there is a relationship we  use a chi-square test is there a  relationship between gender and the  preferred newspaper we have two  categorical variables so we use a  chi-square test our null hypothesis is  there is no relationship between gender  and the preferred newspaper and our  alternative hypothesis is there is a  relationship between gender and the  preferred newspaper